[Music]
all right so let's get back to that 10
seconds of videos you know the exact
line even though everyone says a heck of
a job brownie they don't even get that
right you actually say brownie you're
doing a heck of it yeah yeah I just want
to clean that up for you because even
that line day they don't get right ok
how many days into the hurricane was
that oh gosh I want to say is maybe four
maybe five days I've kind of I can flake
time but four five okay so four or five
days yeah what now I watched plenty of
other video today of what you were doing
at the time and there's you're standing
there people can see this on YouTube
you're standing there with giant maps of
the whole area it was very clear to me
at least watching it now that you had
total command of where things were who
was supposed to be where where water was
going to hit harder and this you know
and drugged bush you know it's his
credit he it seemed that he was
listening along with you and you know
doing the best job I think that he could
after was it it was it three minutes
after he says that that you realized
there that the media went crazy with it
that was the minute it was the minute he
said it because here's what you don't
know but you what most people don't know
is that I had told the I called Air
Force One and said when he lands and
gets here I need five minutes before we
do any sort of public photo-op and when
you even if my level of the
undersecretary even when you say I got
to have five minutes with the president
they still want to know why and I said
because he's got to understand before he
walks in front of cameras how bad things
are New Orleans because we're gonna
leave that Air National Guard base get
on marine one and we're gonna fly to New
Orleans and he's gonna start seeing how
screwed up it is in New Orleans and I
want to make sure he understands that
before he gets there so sure we got
plenty time so we walk into the green
room I'm just starting to talk to the
president and they come in and say we
got to get moving presses out here we're
already running late and they pulling
that and I don't have time to breathe
man it is Wow so the moment and here's
what really happened Bob Riley who was
the Governor of Alabama former
congressman good friend of mine we were
doing great now Alabama things were
perfect in Alabama perfect things were
very good in Mississippi it was just
Louisiana so Bob Riley being the
supporting guy that he is said oh by the
way mr. president I just want you to
know the theme was doing a great job in
Alabama and that's when the president
said boo
slapped me in the gut and it was that
moment Dave that I knew oh my god now
three things have happened the press
knows that I've got a relationship with
the president I have a nickname so I'm
one of the few people in the inner
circle that has a nickname to the press
knows how bad things are in New Orleans
and now both me and the boss look like
we're totally out of touch about what's
happening down the Gulf I mean there's
so much there you really realize how
this was happening yeah I I was if you
watch that closely you'll see me grimace
because I was just like holy yeah so
okay so once that happened how much of
what your job became was just dealing
with media craziness total total not
just the media but now with a Secretary
of Homeland Security by the name of
Michael Chertoff who had never done any
sort of operations in his life he was an
appellate court judge yeah an appellate
court judge has clerks that bring your
briefs and say here's what we think your
decisions should be you sit behind the
desk you take your time you don't
realize that if you put off a decision
for 30 minutes in the middle of a
disaster that translates to three hours
and that costs lives so now I'm dealing
with a Boston DC that doesn't have a
clue what he's doing
who's mad at me because I'm on a
Gulfstream trying to get from mobile to
Gulfport to Baton Rouge to New Orleans
and trying to keep my fingers on
everything going on who tells me I'm
tired of you flying around because I
can't find you and I'm thinking you
can't find me I'm on a government
Gulfstream that's got saddling you can
find me anywhere in the world if you
want to
so tells me to plant life
in Baton Rouge and I turn to my staff
and say this is the beginning of the end
they're after me
the media is after me Chertoff after me
they're looking for a scapegoat I'm not
that stupid I know what's going on yeah
are there any points of criticism during
that time that you think are yes yeah
yes I have a friend who is a
psychiatrist at the Kennedy School of
Government and the School of Public
Health and I asked him one time I said
there was a point during Katrina where
you haven't known me but a few minutes
now but I think you can tell I'm a
pretty type-a person person pretty
energetic I'm pretty engaged in whatever
I do I'm passionate about what I do and
I asked my buddy I said so I know that
there was a point where I was just
frozen I literally could not make a
decision what happened what happens he
drew me a cartoon and it's a cart you
know the great Wizard of Oz well it's a
picture of me in the first panel pushing
all these buttons and levers and turning
wheels and stuff and in the second panel
I'm staring at that same group of
buttons like what's going on and in the
third panel I've gone around look behind
and all the wires have been cut and he
says that physiologically whether it's
it's a it's PTSD it's a natural
phenomena in the brain that when we are
trained like if I if I have trained
myself that when I tell my staff do X I
expect X to happen when you and I turn
on these lights or flip a switch we
expect the lights to come on now you add
all of the physical stress the emotional
stress and nothing is working the brain
starts to shut down and I will freely
admit and this is why I I to this day I
saw a firefighter the other day on the
street was having lunch and I walked up
to him and I said what are you doing
we've been doing training and I'm taking
the guys out for lunch and I said well
you don't know who I am
let me just tell you that
yeah you know making sure those guys
have time off and that they get rest
that's the most important thing you can
do because if they don't get rest when
they're fighting the fires they
themselves can become victims of that
disaster so we've got to learn to train
ourselves that when we're under that
kind of stress you have to be able to
step back and this is when I speak about
resilience I've learned to try to teach
audiences that we all have a network and
what we have to do is learn that when we
find ourselves in those moments that
we're either not making the right
decisions
or we're not making decisions we need
some external force to come in and kind
of slap some sense into us and say
change your perspective what I see is
this if somebody had helped me do that
during Katrina
- still had the presidential bus running
over but at least I would have known why
and what was happening but is that
almost counter to the way a sort of big
government has to operate yes it is
right like you can't go running around
smacking people are trying to get him to
wake up because the machine is so stiff
right but but what I needed and you
could my very best friend of my lawyer
Andy Lester who went through all the
congressional hearings with me to this
day he'll tell you he regrets not
getting in his car and driving to Baton
Rouge because he's watching this from a
distance and he's seeing what's
happening and he knows me well enough
that he could tell that I'm just frozen
like nothing's working what do I do next
and I just needed that external force to
come in and say you're right nothing's
working here's why let's take inventory
have you slept no I haven't slept for
three days maybe you ought to go try to
take an ambien at least get four hours
of sleep it's that kind of stuff that
makes a huge but at that point also with
what was happening because of the media
you were sort of just in a feeding
frenzy oh it was like a self-fulfilling
absolutely self-fulfilling it's right
you know to this day I am always amazed
I mean I could I could go through the
litany of falsehoods that I'm no longer
defensive about because they're
falsehoods and it is what it is and I
love talking about
them in front of you know corporate CEOs
and titans of industry who think they
know that they can run everything well
let me tell you someday the prefer the
proverbial feces is gonna hit the fan
and you're happening and you're gonna
want to learn these lessons and learn
them well that's why I run a small
business here we have a very very very
good what what do you make of just sort
of the I guess this is just part of the
human condition the idea that we always
need someone to blame now you are
acknowledging that not everything went
right you didn't make every right
decision we're acknowledging government
over you know nonsense and all that but
just this need to blame because I think
you are one of the first examples
because maybe it was sort of it that
just at the beginnings of social media
or lines and I'm just like let's just
take this guy didn't know who he was yes
long enough and let's just destroy that
let's we'll destroy his career and then
we'll try to destroy his life yeah what
do you what do you make of just that
general psychological well then there is
a there's two ways to look at it in
Judaism there is the the philosophy of
finding the scapegoat and putting all
the sins of the community putting all
the sins of the village and escape on
the goat and throwing the goat over the
cliff well I think that really is
applicable to life in general and we
have through social media I can't I
can't even imagine what I would have
been like with social media back in 2005
it was brutal enough without it but I
think we have when you think about the
hierarchy of needs that people have the
long love power social media has
amplified all of those and the the
feeling of being superior to somebody
else so permeates our society that any
chance we have to squish somebody it
makes I don't know whether it's an
endorphin rush adrenaline but something
that we now have this horrible horrible
desire to just destroy people they have
lives they have families now some people
maybe they deserve it maybe them but I
like to think that everybody unless
you're just totally the doofus people
are actually trying to do the best they
can
yeah I mean I'm a firm believer in that
yeah but yes of course there
are people that want to just destroy
them unfortunately I think social media
amplify the best antidote to that is me
because I refused to stay down there
were people that actually advised me you
need to slither away and I was like are
you kidding I cannot wait for these
congressional hearings because I can't
wait for some dumbass congressman or
dumbass senator who thinks that he's
God's gift to creation to ask me a
question because I'm gonna telling the
truth whether he likes it or not so
let's talk about those hearings a little
bit because when you see it just any
here right any hearing related to any
yeah it strikes me as patently obvious
that pretty much the senator is M
congressman have almost no idea what
they're talking about really right but
they've been handed a brief career and
they've been told by probably you know
handler or whoever these are the three
questions you got to ask because we got
to get you on CNN tonight so then you
can push this and blah blah just did the
hearings when they're trying to
unpackage all of this do the hearings
ever make things better at the end like
is there a hearing that ends and then
they go we really solved the problems of
why Katrina happened why the levees fail
what the problems were with Nemo or
other responders etcetera etcetera
rarely in fact let me tell you it's
actually worse than what you think it
right it's just more government growing
it's no it's more government growing but
to tell you how bad it really is and
there if as the undersecretary if I'm
gonna testify now I was a private
citizen when I testified in the in the
Katrina hearing yeah wait just to be
clear so how long after the the yeah
brownie you know until you until you
resigned well I actually interestingly I
resigned on September 11th of 2005 but
then they came to me and said oh we need
you to stay on because we've got to
figure out just what's going on because
they're gonna come after the
administration so we went to plow we
want to keep you in the fold for a while
so they kept me on as a consultant force
I want to say four or five months
afterwards and then I pulled it you must
be seriously pissed at that but now you
knew you were just yes so I pulled the
trigger and said no more consulting I'm
a private citizen
and so when I'm called to testify the
White House has to do one of two things
they have to be there except that I'm
gonna tell the truth or they have to
invoke executive privilege and prevent
me from testifying and we deliberately
set it up with Susan Collins and Joe
Lieberman for Senator Lieberman to ask
me a question
so about conversations with the
President or the White House so that
when that question was asked my lawyer
could say my client wants to answer the
question but he cannot if the White
House is going to invoke executive
privilege which then allowed senator
Lieberman see how the charade works yeah
then allows senator Lieberman to ask is
there anyone in this hearing room from
the White House who wants to invoke
executive privilege and of course the
room silent thank you sure that works
right and since early Bruin laughed and
said well I'm sure there are plenty of
people from the White House here but
apparently nobody wants to invoke
executive privilege mr. Brown answer the
question and then we were off to the
races but to go back about just a
regular hearing yeah if an
undersecretary or any other government
official is going to go testify his
testimony is cleared through the Office
of Management and Budget that testimony
is given to the senators and congressmen
in advance the questions are given to
the witness in advance it is a show it
is a production how much of it also is
that they're asking you things as if
everything sort of works perfectly in
any of the hearings you know in Hillary
the Benghazi knows where they're asking
minute by minute what did you say then
to this person that person I mean I know
in my own daily life you ask me what
happened three three days ago at noon
right you know I don't know I don't know
I'd have to think about it for a while
but me and maybe I can maybe maybe no
you come up with it right yeah but just
that they they're trying to get you on
every little thing plus the pressures of
your you're under oath right the media
watching and everybody else I mean it
just seems like it's a recipe for
nothing - nothing good nothing
substantial to comment nothing
substantial does come out of them now I
think there's an exception if if in the
House or Senate if they are truly
conducting an investigation and here's
how to tell if they're truly
conducting an investigation they'll
deposed witnesses outside the hearing
room they will ask a witness either
voluntarily or with subpoena to come in
and subject to a deposition by staff
lawyers that's a real investigation
that's really sitting you down and
saying swear to tell the truth the whole
truth nothing but the truth
now let us ask you a series of questions
and that can actually result in
something productive now for the witness
you have to be very careful because like
anything else to your point what you
doing Wednesday at noon I you know I
went to went to this bagel shop down the
street and had lunch what was the name
of it well I think it was X they find
that actually you went to a burger stand
and had a burger now they got you in
perjury yeah
it's crazy really is quickly so what was
the resolution and when the hearings
ended like what do they do so then they
issue a report the report they're a part
brand and the report what the report I
get a kick out of this because the
report virtually acknowledged everything
that I had said was wrong about the
integration of FEMA and these other
agencies in the DHS there was a virtual
admission to that then the things that
they wanted to do to correct were I
don't want to over exaggerate so let's
just say 50% they in essence adopted
about 50% of the things I've been
arguing about now is it working it's not
working because the way things go in DC
whoever has the money has the power and
you can't won them I'm using the FEMA
current FEMA director who's a former
employee of mine is an example you can't
expect him on a day-to-day well what's
his name Brock Brock long okay used to
be the at the National Hurricane Center
emergency manager in Alabama he's a
great guy I love this guy
probably should have said that because
that he'll probably regret having said
that we don't know but you probably made
his can
yeah exactly so it was like my family
well that the the reports the reports so
if you're fighting on a day-to-day basis
for your budget with the Secretary of
Homeland Security and all the other
under secretaries and then when a
disaster hits now you're the boss and
the secretary is subordinate to you can
you imagine doing that in the private
sector
one day you're the CEO but under certain
circumstances you as the CEO are
actually subordinate to somebody else on
your staff I mean that's an untenable
situation but that's kind of the
situation they created with the post
Katrina act that's crazy
so we touched obviously on the media
portion of this and I mentioned how when
I was googling you this morning as I'm
doing research half the articles come up
or about the 10-year Android sorry and
they're still attacking yes
now again you have sat here and
acknowledge that you did not do
everything perfectly but but what is it
what do you make of that in a more broad
sense about the media because I talk
about the media out here and I'm
extremely frustrated with mainstream
media and it's almost gotten to the
point where every time they write
something bad about somebody I start
thinking that they're actually the good
guy no because I see the way I do it to
me right that the media really has
completely gotten out of control
they've lost they've lost all integrity
they've lost all this is what I do in my
own radio program is I don't tell I
don't ever try to tell people what to
think I try to give them a different
perspective so that they can with their
own minds maybe think about something a
different way the media if you look for
those ten year anniversary things
there's a one example that just stands
out that to this day irritates me I had
the highest level of security clearances
with the CIA the NSA I had a Q clearance
with the Department of Energy which
means I had access to all the nuke
secrets and everything else I mean I
top-secret special exercise access
programs that was me I don't know you're
gonna drop any other secret knowledge
that's right so I had all these
clearances and everything else Time
magazine ran a story that I had lied on
my resume
now my first reaction when they ran that
story was sue the bastards I want to go
after him and then my lawyer starts
to me okay first of all you're gonna
have to prove they did it with willful
malice because you're a public figure
then you're gonna have to go through all
of the strain and time and energy of
depositions and a trial and hearings and
you want to relive all of that or do you
really care about Time magazine having
some story that's now 10 12 15 years old
about you lied on your resume when you
know what the truth is and half of
America knows what the truth is and the
other half of America you don't really
care about yeah no but the media gets by
with it now I am NOT I am NOT repeat NOT
going down the road the Trump goes down
that says we need to change the libel
laws I'm just pointing out that the
media has this amazing power and with
that power I believe comes
responsibility and they've abdicated the
responsibility yeah you know I'm 50/50
on the libel thing and everyone that's
watching the show knows that I am an
absolute free speech absolutist that's
an absolute twice right but I do believe
in libel laws and yeah I do believe we
should hire three laws to protect
privacy right and a series of other
things I don't know if I would prefer
that they don't be changed because I
don't think we need the government doing
it I don't think we need more laws I
don't think we need more regulations or
any of that right yet there is something
that I see so consistently these days
where they just pick somebody and it's
off I mean it's often people that I have
on this show because they're right and
thick of important conversations and we
say one thing here and then I read the
article about it the day after and it's
literally the reverse or they cut the
word not right you know or didn't it's
what I have found that I find
fascinating yeah and I know that media
is in this transition you I mean look
what you and I are doing they hate what
you and I are doing right now because it
throws what it fills our business model
out the window yeah I think what they
like I'll I'll be doing a story on air
and I've got the article in front of me
and I'm a kind of grammar nut and I'll
look at I'll go holy crap an editor
never even looked at this The Wall
Street Journal I get to either stellar
newspaper right yeah I have they fired
all their editors I find so many
grammatical errors punctuation errors
all I just think the media
is in this flux so you add the flux with
their agenda at times their sloppiness
you had all of those things together the
media is just not filling their Fourth
Estate responsibilities yeah so how do
we clean up some of this government
stuff
I suspect although you just said you're
not with Trump on the book I suspect
that there's a certain amount of
deregulation that he's doing and cutting
back some of these agencies that you've
got to be pretty happy with static about
it
when you think about this all this is
you'll find this a bizarre example but
whether it's here in California are back
in Colorado wherever wherever we might
might be I challenge people watching
this go look at any government office
and I would bet it's the nicest office
building in your community now wait a
minute
who paid for that the guys in the garage
who are coming up with the next big
thing a some startup company or some guy
that's working an 8 to 5 blue-collar job
that it's got his hands dirty and his
nails are cracked and he's working with
his hands like crazy they're paying for
that is it shouldn't it be the reverse
shouldn't the government actually be in
the garages shouldn't they actually be
the ones that are in the office
buildings that you know they have to go
up 20 elevators to get their offices
instead of having all the edifice 'iz
that we allow them to use and create and
build we have this we have this
perverted sense that the government and
I think it's getting worse that the
government is the answer to everything
and that somehow government is going to
solve all of our problems let me tell
you the government doesn't solve
problems the government causes problems
so what would you say the answer is
related to so a DHS or FEMA now or
anything else I mean if these things
didn't exist I'm sure somebody's
watching this right tell me what do you
mean I mean if these things didn't exist
well now you know
Norrell and still is below sea level
which is a hole in that you know that
right let's just talk about that for you
like there are a certain amount of
people that now say well wait a minute
wait a minute because they don't realize
it then they here and they go wait a
minute we have a city that's below sea
level that has all of these you know
structural problems
maybe we shouldn't be living there
anymore what do you say to someone like
that well first of all I think anybody
should be able to live wherever they
want to live if if I want to live next
to the National Forest in Boulder County
Colorado I should be able to do that but
then I should also assume the risk of
living there if I want to live on the
fault lines in California I should be
able to do that but I should assume the
risk yeah I think government has some
basic services to provide we all agree
that police protection fire protection
that's something we all want to pay for
but if you're going to deliberately
choose to live below sea level and then
why should I want to be very careful I
can feel it aren't any why it's slippery
yeah it's slippery because I think they
should be able to live there if you
choose to live there though it's the
responsibility of the tax payers that
live there to create those levies and
build those levies and maintain those
levies because I don't live there it's
not my responsibility
I pay taxes to take care of the hazards
where I live and frankly I don't think
that government should take care of all
hazards because if we tried to start if
we start trying to protect the American
population from all of the hazards that
we face we will end up with a
totalitarian government because there's
too many hazards so this is this is sort
of the case where the people that that
were down there in New Orleans that
Allah it's not just I'm sure most of
them had or and I can't say most but I'm
sure a good portion at least of the
people that had money had insurance and
probably had flood insurance and
everything else but it's that afterwards
all this federal money comes in to help
the rebuild but you're saying there
perhaps that that doesn't quite make
sense is that is that base yes and there
will be people who will say oh my god
the former director of Federal Emergency
Management Agency is saying we should
revisit absolutely we have a concept of
federalism in this country we have
federal state and local government and
at at the top leg let's reverse that we
have the people we have local government
state government and federal government
that's the order and what we have done
is we have taken the federal government
and we've almost made them the local
fire department we've almost made them
the local police department in a mini
aspects that's actually true TSA for
example that we've made them the local
police department that even though I'm
going to be a lawyer here they have no
law enforcement authority they just
think they do say they have zero law
enforcement authority what does it
actually mean they have zero law
enforcement authority I mean they if you
go through and you've got a knife in
your pocket well I go then they just
hand you off to whoever locally and you
gotta give it up as I gotta get a cop
they can't they can't arrest you they
can't detain you they can't do anything
but they call themselves officers
because they want to put on the mask of
authority because government always
wants to put on the mask of authority
because that's how you keep the citizens
kind of subdued well my whole point
about FEMA becoming kind of this first
responder the more we rely on the
federal government to come in after any
sort of disaster that weakens state and
local governments because they become
more and more dependent upon the federal
government so more and more things get
nationalized and the more things get
nationalized
the more we turn into a Western European
socialist type government which we know
it's not gonna happen in our lifetime so
don't get me wrong I'm not the tinfoil
hats not now but but I do believe that
the public's eventually fail and we are
on this path that if we keep going down
this path of throwing more and more
things up against the wall for the
federal government to to handle and take
care of we will end up as a Western
European socialist government and over
generations and generations that leads
to tyranny so then you must be digging
trunk on this oh and this stuff
absolutely yeah the thing the thing that
bothers me look the the president wasn't
my first choice yet and I before we go
too deep on him I do want to mention
that we are taping this a little bit in
advance of when it's going to air so
wasn't my first choice but when it came
down to the to the typical dichotomy a
Republican versus Democrat you know I
still think so I still want to believe
that Republicans are the government of
individualism and individual
pretty and everything although I can
argue that they aren't necessarily that
way and the Democrats are moving to the
hard progressive almost Marxist left so
when it comes to the general election if
I want to vote for one of those two I'm
gonna vote for Trump I only say that
because he has totally upended what it
means I worked for George W Bush who
people thought couldn't speak well but I
thought was smart knew what he was doing
I think Trump is smart I think he knows
what he's doing
but he's the first president in this age
of Twitter and Facebook and everything
else and I just don't think we've quite
figured out how to deal with that and
quite honestly I don't think he's quite
figured out how to deal with it he
hasn't quite figured out that as
president if I say something even
innocuous they're reading that in
Beijing they're reading that in Moscow
they're reading that in in Pyongyang
they're reading it everywhere and so he
needs to be a little more I just wish
you would be a little more circumspect
in the use of social media yeah
all right enough about Trump just talk
about George W Bush for a second because
you mention he was he was your boss you
know well you know there was the
caricature of course of all the years of
his presidency that he was some sort of
idiot or you know yes he had a strange
way of speaking and kind of stilted and
Roseman you know right yes a lot of that
right he mixed up a lot of words I mean
tell me something about him that maybe
would give us a little other side that
we wouldn't know there's an odd
nostalgia that's one is there's an odd
nostalgia about him now because I see it
from people on the left all the time now
they're they're sort of galvanizing him
right there they're lionizing him now
because if you keep I've he and I were
in the limo we were in the beasts
Southern California going back to marine
one and we're on these kind of rural
areas and people have lined the streets
and Eddie who was his agent in charge of
the presidential detail he kept telling
Eddie and I wouldn't use these words
carefully Eddie
stopped the car
these people want to see their president
it wasn't Eddie stop the car they gonna
see me and he don't stop the car because
they want to see you know hey it's me
and brown no they want to see their
president he had this understanding of
that office was his temporarily and he
was everybody's president and I saw that
in that car and then I saw it one time
in the Oval Office and we were sitting
in and press office comes through with a
gaggle of kids and he stops the meeting
entirely and shows these kids I mean
they miss maybe sixth grade or seventh
graders shows them the resolute desk and
explains to them the history the
resolute desk and I'm sitting there like
I could watch this all day long yeah
then a third story we heard he was the
first presidential debate of the 2004
election he jab and I are in the car
we've been at some hurricane center
somewhere and Jeb turns to him and says
I think it's time to feed your hotel you
need to you really need to bone up and
study some and Bush is like now you know
I'm woke up his ass he was kind of a
frat boy with yeah with alone he was
kind of a frat boy jocular funny
crack jokes you know smarted off never
inappropriately but just ordinary human
being so these two brothers get in a
fight and I'm sitting in the jump seat
facing the president like I am you and
Jeb sitting there and they're arguing
about whether they should go back to the
hotel or now and Jeb looks at me and
says Helen and I'm like I am NOT gonna
get the fight between two brothers one
who's the governor of a swing state that
we've got to win this election in and
the other guy happens to be the
president United States is my boss I'm
staying out of that fight boys and what
happened I stayed out of the fight and
and Bush went to that first debate and
lost big time to John Kerry there you go
well listen it's really been a pleasure
talking to you I hope we cleaned up some
of this stuff - did we hit everything
that that should have been hit on
are you kidding we could I mean I know
we call more days yeah yeah you got to
go do your radio show but not too far
from here right but I suspect we'll do
this again I hope so yeah it was a
pleasure absolutely oh and by the way I
want to mention I you know I've talked
to the people over here for those of you
that follow us on patreon so many of you
know that my dog Emma is a rescue from
Hurricane Katrina and she's got a really
wonderful story so we did a video of
Michael meeting Emma before and I and I
told her story and that's on patreon and
for more on Michael you can follow him
on Twitter it's at Michael Brown USA
[Music]
you
[Music]